we good friend researcher at Microsoft
Research in Bangalore and my opinion one
of the one of the test researchers in
the area of optimization these days you
might have seen some of his papers and
the Contras that we care about there was
a lot of presentation that's here at
idea tight and and some fun facts about
for needs other than effective educator
researcher it was my lab mate at UT
Austin and when we were doing on PhD it
was also my neighbor and for some time
we shared the same Wi-Fi connection okay
and he has also seen me when I had long
hair so he knows what how that disaster
picture I will leave you with thank you
so the tile of the top you saw this in
India before I gave you the details of
the path let me give you a high-level
overview of the kind of perspective
between and as most of us are probably
optimization is a crucial part of a
machine learning these days and
stochastic population based methods that
are specifically in design are the
workhorses that actually type all these
optimization answer Thanks
and there are several updates of
gradient descent that people use in
practice so examples include mini
batching we compute the stochastic
gradient of single examples but on a
collection of mini backup examples then
the second one that I mention here is
model averaging where basically in the
context of disputed optimization there
we have
machines and we say maybe different
models on different machines and then
you want to combine all these different
models to get a much better model - each
of them new TVs then third one means
acceleration which is knock termination
techniques which has been developed to
speed up the convergence of gradient
based algorithms so that they run faster
and this is also used in practice and
finally the one with the dimension here
we use about running wreck stadiums so
what essentially great additional tools
and algorithm progresses or should I
change the running rate to get the best
performance of the algorithm right so
these are some of the key aspects of
vaguely design and empirically people do
a lot of work on figuring out how to use
of these things in order to get the best
performance out of the implementation
right while these are very important in
practice from a technical point of view
there is very little understanding of
how exactly these all these things
affect the performance of stochastic
gradient set your non simple problems so
our work focuses on a thorough
investigation of all of these aspects
for the specific case of stochastic
linear equations okay and the reason we
work with stochastic linear regression
is because the simple structure of the
table and explain what ink that is to
test is an efficient but the reason we
move on like this very specific and
simple problem is that the like already
in this context though like all of the
answering all of these questions already
comes non-trivial but it is possible to
do it and the very simple structure of
the problem that was actually answer
this question and the second thing is
even though whatever we do in theory the
point of view applies only just
graphically in a regression so high
level conclusions that we draw from this
seem to carry over more complicated
models as well so that's the bedroom and
in this talk I will be exposing we
focusing on the work that we did on
acceleration in the stochastic setting
for sophisticated okay so let me now
start by giving you a brief primer on
optimization and there is no better
place to start
and we decide which is one of the most
fundamental optimization algorithms so
given a function f thank you for the
nice gradient descent computes the bring
it at the time point and then moves in
the negative - company again so in the
parameter step side and then we move in
the negative gradient direction
depending on how large the step sizes I
mentioned will be solely interested in
the stop for the linear regression
problem there the function f is given by
x transpose w minus y square here X is a
matrix W is a vector I'm going to vector
so x and y are given to us and we wish
to minimize this function over W so
that's a problem and as you can imagine
this is an extremely basic problem and
Iverson several applications and before
this reason this has been extensively
studied in literature okay
and one of the most basic questions that
arises here is we use gradient descent
for solving this linear regression
problem how fast do we expect to how
much do we expect getting descent to
actually find a solution to this problem
right and in order to quantify this
motion I need to find this quantity
called the initial number of the power
so the condition number is given by the
issue of the largest eigen value of this
matrix X transpose - the smallest eigen
value of a system yeah so then so there
are two kind of analysis that I can do
one is you get this geometric
convergence rate so you take a long
dependence on this one so you can also
do a analysis where this is equal to
zero you get a different kind of
convergence rate ah
so in this storm I'll be focusing on
this forming what is known as strongly
convex anyway this is not equal to C and
the result you get usually for something
unless and also we transfer to the non
from the context by adding a regular
basis and itself it so we assume that
the setting is - the condition number is
not is reckoning that like we know my
value is not equal to 0 in this point X
is ID in order to buy extra the minimum
value of F
and epsilon is my family life meaning
that I want to find it point of view
that I hope that we - s value that
motive target then the number of
vibrations that gradient descent takes
my second point which satisfies this
inequality is not the condition of the
kaabah it is defined here right initial
number times log of initials of
optimality divides like a typo so this
is a number of iterations then gradient
descent requires find an epsilon target
or epsilon and so the larger the number
of iterations it why it is larger okay
so in actually in here is better this
rate that we have here is this light so
okay so far radiator side when I spell
input this er here if we set for video
Edison this is not to be type by getting
that on there are problems where they
intersect I'll require these many
vibrations we find a solution so the
question is can we design a new
algorithm which can do better than this
condition number linear dependence on
the condition so the thing in the law is
usually not of too much importance so
what we are mostly interested in is this
dependence on condition which is we near
here and in actual question is whether
you move the dependence from condition
number from linear to something but if I
the fourth is that gradient descent does
not actually use any of the posterior at
any regression and you see only the
current gradient
I don't even though have seen that above
the blue team I'm on t minus 2 and so on
I am only using the current gradient so
can we design a more intermediate
algorithm which users will be all the
fast lenient husband that can actually
get me a better cover your face and it
turns out this intuition is and we
several famous algorithms which do this
examples include on your gradient fully
upside evolve method and that's
absolutely radiant these methods in
general also known as momentum method I
example let us look at this house as if
it is really insane how it looks like
and what is its convergence rate so the
necessary
descent rate is too high rates we
gender-neutral
so maybe I only had one eye trick
whereas this ability it has boy tricks
we can end up using and there are two
kind of steps so one is once one kind of
steps of the variant steps the other
ones are momentum self so from 3d make a
gradient step ok WT plus 1 and from WB +
1 we take a moment of step to get maybe
plus 1 and then from B plus 1 you are
getting take ingredient step to think of
the P plus 1 so we have a boy traits and
two kinds of steps and this is of the
algorithm in equation form this is how
it looks like and the exact form of the
equations is not important but what I
want to stress here is that the amount
of time taken per update of per
iteration of network accelerated
gradient he's pretty much the same as
that I can buy an item of Grady design
so in terms of correlation cost the
amount of time taken to implement one
iteration of this acceleration trading
is pretty much the same as the amount of
time taken for one equation readings
ellipsis
the convergence rate meaning the number
of iterations required and not would be
why I wrote the condition number rather
than a linear dependence on condition
number that we had for various radii
decide you have in this video dependent
condition number there has for
accelerated reading this X we have
initial number is the quality is always
better than equal to 1 because it's max
Goldman
so if always return 4 to 1 Y roof is
always better than papa
so the activated rating method is always
better than begin descent and one might
wonder whether receive actually hides
like very large constant factors and
whether this is really practical useful
or not and it turns out that like even
on simple examples this is already
extremely much better than gradient
descent so here I am showing you of
course for gradient descent in the blue
and I'm still getting variant is that
right now for a hundred eventual linear
regression problem with addition of our
country and you can already see that the
error of the way XS so isolated region
is about 10 times faster than radiation
to reach the same level of tactics okay
so even in practice this is
like extremely useful and gives a lot of
improvements over variants so this was
all the background that I wanted to give
you on optimization in the deterministic
settings now problems with machine
learning
so in machine learning they usually
don't have a fix on ship so we get
everything off I say the supervised
setting where we get n samples from an
underlying distribution x1 y1 all the
way up to xn yn and we usually write
down the empirical empirical function
which is 1 over n number of samples
summation over I over all the samples in
the rehydration setting exposed of the -
wire goes where you are trying to say a
linear predictor 2 x AI comma Y and in
practice what we do you solve this
empirical problem which is 1 over N
summation I gospel simply - y a Forsman
but the ultimate goal is actually not to
get very good accuracy on this empirical
problem but rather to get a very good
error on the to a true expectation over
the true distribution right so my
ultimate goal is to actually minimize
expectation or the tribution of X
transpose w minus y whole square right
this is my ultimate goal and you cannot
directly apply gradient design on this
problem right text because gradient
skill involved computing an expectation
over the following distribution and we
don't have access to the exact
distribution all we have access to these
samples that we have seen from this so
this setting has been extremely well
today I move by the name of stochastic
approximation and there is a natural way
to extend gradient design to this
capacitor proximation second and that's
the motivation for the original paper
that actually proposed this category
give us an algorithm
what is the main idea so the idea is
that you take gradient descent but I'll
replace the gradient it is picasso
activation has been computed just using
one particular data point x keep on the
white and in expectation this stochastic
gradient is equal to the gradient
because these XT YT comes from the same
underlying
that you're thankful for my soul I'm
ponytail edition the update takes this
very simple form so the next hydrate
that will be plus one is the beauty -
reiga and this is the static radiant and
it's extremely easy to compute the
stochastic gradient because we just
compute this inner product and then you
do this linearity and because of
extremely efficient feature is extremely
it's very widely used in practice and
that's also the reason or excuses you
say unique learning and meaning of the
scale machine learning problems they're
completely is extremely important and I
told you how the gradient descent is
practically the same in fact is people
also use variations of other algorithms
so if you so I spoke about a default
method so if you replace gradients to
stochastic gradient since any ball
method is particularly well and
similarly you do it for next or even a
specific national fast residually okay
so these are straightforward extensions
of data mystic algorithms to the
stochastic setting and these are
actually algorithms that people use in
practice now let us try to understand
what is the caste greatly in design in
this capacity optimization second right
so this why hide the middle is exciting
the convergence rate here okay so the
first comes with the special is there
there is a to W star and my actual Y so
the Y the times up is actually equal to
X transpose W star
so there is an underlying truth and let
me tell you what the convergence rate in
this following models where there is not
a line through this way we can again
take a similar algorithm straight as
what we've got in the domestic setting
so you have media dependence on
condition number Papa law of initial
over target over there is a slight
difference in appeal you define the
condition number because you are in the
stochastic city but tumbler just say
okay it remains the same and in the my
see age where you have an additive noise
term so Y is actually predict some folks
every Star Plus and I did have nice you
have an ID typical in another state
which depends on the noise variance
Sigma square
wait delta on the data was hidden in
this no practice papa is this what's
called a realizable case so this is a
really no not getting it all right yeah
the earth the gradients do maybe five
degrees you don't need it so I mean in
this case you will get a negative down
based on nice gradients you not yeah you
think they get reduction yeah I mean it
depends on your problem it could be
anything greater than equal to one yeah
good okay so now let me try to recap all
the things that we have also in the
domestic is we saw that radiator side
have been here comes Williams linear
dependence on function number and that's
what I'm selected radiant has pyro
depends on this condition of right this
improves and it comes out like this is
the optimal for the thickness exciting
as well okay so now exciting you have
this linear dependence from condition
number and then of course an eye detail
terms that depends on the nicely so the
question we want to ask is acceleration
in the stochastic matrix very possible
just like what we did is a different
city so in the domestic setting we
improve a spoil of Aqaba in the pigeon
in a domestic setting can we do
something better than so sp3d okay so
that's the bottom portion that you want
to ask and i need to qualify intercept
ignore the quality terms of fact i think
the second term is statistically optimal
okay there is not a little that can
actually improve on this second term so
all you can improve on is actually only
this first term so that's basically the
question that you asked and what design
you can we improve this dependence on
the condition of our budget so that the
question that we're yeah square root
ah so okay so if you okay so because we
are already looking at this wire loss
kind of thing right so the law so you if
you are looking at capacity in a
decryption you have an X minus X W minus
W star square right I'm W minus W star
that would depend on the order of 100 10
and because you have you are looking at
the function by new defense which is a
square you will get and W star you are
able to exploit within 100 square of
them and because you are looking at
those wire you will get a 1 over here
this is for linear equations and any
kind of smooth problems if you will see
this kind of thing because like yet
optimal rate is equal to 0 and then like
the error is only in the quadratic term
which is the lower bound
like general gradient based methods for
like like for the stochastic here which
musician yeah so interesting the so if
you look at the schematic approximation
sitting there are no competition there
only see the lower box okay and those
kids who we kept at this time they won't
at this term I'm sitting next one is of
course for the online this is like
mystical Barbie doesn't matter whatever
to use you cannot go up on this I mean
we can take care of that but the
information theoretic bounds all for the
online setting may be Commission
Kennedy's bonds old for both online and
offline they don't care about how you do
the competition okay it's just like if
you see these many samples this is the
bet again also here the transportation
thank you sure yes because they keep you
just want to minimize the financing
yeah if you want to do the finance and
then you have foundational bonds but if
you care about the to expert near then
you finished 30 globe on say if you see
these examples is the best freak'n the
why there is a like I assume dismal
nicety and that forgiveness in the
mighty case you have a sorry kept them
untouched basically what i have yes so
here you make the distinction I think oh
ah yeah in the actual here COAS know you
yeah yeah so before I try to answer this
question so let me first tell you why we
think this is really important and the
reason is that as we saw earlier right
so heavy ball I'm necessarily brilliant
propose for the specific setting you can
easily make them stochastic by just
replacing gradients which has two
gradients and people do use them in
practice a lot and any determining like
package that you look at as the momentum
parameter we basically influence in some
people to use it in practice and so in
the difference is I think you already
saw like evolution can actually you can
be productive movement and even in these
stochastic settings it seems like people
are actually observing a lot of
improvements and there is some earlier
work as well which was that if you can
activate it could help you in designing
more parallel algorithms as well so on
the whole the point I'm trying to make
here is that in practice we do expect to
get full improvement if we can
accelerate in the stochastic setting but
right now people are using heuristics
and you would like to understand whether
there is a way to actually be able to do
this even though the stochastic say okay
and there is there is some earlier work
on understanding stochastic unipolar and
a straw
in some organizations it is by gas
Beaumont and the lenient plan but so
saying that they consider is different
from the widget learning setting and so
in short they instead of like fixed
variance fittings which are not
reflective of like those so tactically
in a regression problem and so on but
you got more interested is the
difference in settings I can talk to you
more okay so with this let me are trying
to give you a broad outline of
quadriceps and then I go into each of
the so the first question that we ask is
whether it's possible to improve the
linear West final just like they had in
their acoustic setting and it turns out
the answer to this is no until cases
where like information theory it's not
possible to know the condition for
depends so is it ever possible to
improve I actually can improve on some
substance but then it has depend on
other problem parameters and not just on
the condition of okay and the third
thing is because we are saying that in
some cases improvement is possible to
existing algorithms like this come
asking questions of heavy polar missed
all that people are using in practice do
they keep this improvement whenever it
is one word and the surprising answer to
this doesn't agree that they cannot and
in fact they are no better than this G
and this is actually very surprising
also given the fact that in fact is like
people are using this and they are
observing some scrubs so I will get to
this like apparent contradiction towards
the end of my talk and the final
question that we ask is whether we can
so because these methods don't work can
we design you a little bit at to improve
or specifically design and get some
proven improvements on this problem and
we do design such an algorithm which we
call activated specifically in assent or
ASD so at the research sphere I'll
explain each of them in more detail
Thanks so the first question is whether
it's always possible to add the rate
categories okay
and I'd like to illustrate answer to
this question
example I like lips just comes ready -
anywhere there is a crude of this bar
and Y is equal to X transpose M yeah
what is it like for ya for any complex
objection yeah it could be related to
non-public scheme yeah it's possible but
I will give you I get to 8% of my yeah
so yes so the first question that you
ask is where the oxidation is always
possible and so we'll try to illustrate
on the dispersion in the context of life
there like that was water where Y is
actually equal to X transpose W cell for
some fixed of this path right so in this
setting the registering of SVD is given
by as you saw earlier condition number
log of quantity and one would hope that
maybe we can improve this condition
number two esquire 'was condition right
so that's a book waiting from the
ethnicity so more completely so let me
define a distribution over X which is
food original vector so it's equal to 1
0 with probability 0.9999 and 0 on the
probability point 0 0 0 1 ok most of the
times it's 1 0 and 1 and in this case
the condition of blood comes out to be 1
over this ability which is 10 to the
fourth okay and the pushin we're asking
is whether we can get a convergence rate
of square root of conditional value of
this quantity and it's simpler question
if you want to just ignore this law is
to say if I'm given the initial point
can I have the error of the initial
point using whatever condition number or
both hundred samples okay so if I just
give you 100 steps or hundred samples
can you have the insurer and once you
stare at it for some time it's actually
not if they could see that cap any fewer
than k2 the core sample file you are
never going to observe an example in
this - right because this probability is
like 10 to the minus 4 so if you observe
any fewer than 10 to the 4 samples you
are not going to observe X equal to 0 1
right
which means that in W star
the vector that you are trying to
estimate you have no measurement on the
second coordinate because only if you
get X equal to 0 1 if you actually
measure something about the second
coordinate and if you never see the 0 1
direction then you cannot pitch of the
second coordinate so if you are than 10
to the 4 samples
you cannot estimate the second component
of the blue star at all right so what
this basically says is that you cannot
do anything better than initial number
like in any information theory sense
it's not about competition or anything
if so make synthetically you cannot do
anything better than any son so
acceleration is not possible at all for
this disc okay so this answers the first
question and that cannot always improve
this condition number yo5 yeah so table
earlier and it's a three of the of the
blocks and you're missing a top right
and one of them you had the accelerated
number of iterations there was a root
Kappa and there was a second term no
it's PI right so you get two terms
yeah it city house condition number of
the post online so my question is any
chance like something similar is
happening in this case like could you
could you actually say that what you are
getting here is something that is a
multi-term result and the first term is
actually root Kappa but it's hidden by
bigger terms is your variable
no so okay so intrinsic sitting there is
only one term right sitting there's only
one only the second and give me some
more orders proper terms possible but
the point is the dominating term is this
papa and the question is can you
increase the dominating term is a
question like if you cannot decrease a
dominating term the presence of other
terms is Maryam is the you design this
example in a way that maybe we can come
up with a come up with a similar example
in the SGD case right a similarly
that tells us no we cannot have this
acceleration well because we have this
extra noise right so what you're doing
yeah so I am shaking like it's not
always possible so now let's get to our
second example so in some countries you
take a discrete distribution let's
consider a Gaussian distribution which I
mean have the same variance matrix so X
is normal zero comma H where H is the
first matrix with 0.9999 and point zero
zero zero one on the diagonals so in
this case the condition number is again
like 10 to the fourth it is same as the
previous sitting drink the condition but
it's still really pretty much but it
turns out that after just two samples
right to get this two samples the two
samples that you get are linearly
independent because you are trying to
compulsion is V and if you get two
independent samples you can actually
avoid the empirical bonus matrix and
then you get exactly mind of the stuff
because like you're looking at - and you
can exactly find out this done so in
this setting at least information
thoroughly it seems like after two
samples we have enough information to
find out this far as the previous
setting you do not have enough
information up there at least tens of
course samples were required right so
interesting addition so many links is
that accusation might be possible and
the key takeaway here is again that it
depends on some other instructions and
not just an additional because we saw
two problems with the same condition
number one pair activation was not
possible and the other one where
activation seems possible so what
exactly is the problem that seems to
capture this and becomes clear when you
write what we're doing here is that the
inverting the entitlement
so the key company that we want from the
sample set we have model is that you
should be able to say that the empirical
covariance matrix which is 1 over N
summation X I X I hope this is empirical
variance matrix it has to be close to
the true
with its head if it is closed then
information 30s we have enough
information to be able to report every
star and if it is not close then you
don't have enough information movement
Omega 30 so how many samples will be
really require or Antipodes matrix to be
true this is a very well studied
question in random matrix theory and
just like we have a notion of variance
course errors you have a notion for
vehicles motion for matrices which is
four minutes radians and in the context
of the current problem we call it
statistical condition number
I am denote it with a buckaroo okay so
we define this new notion called
statistical condition number which we do
not use make up a trip so what exactly
is this papadum for that let's first
look at the ischium page
so are the boys matrix a so that is the
covariance matrix of the exhibition that
I am looking at and these ease on to the
eigen directions of H so this H responds
to the ellipse funny so if any matrix
corresponds any politics of mine ethnic
minutes ten points to an ellipse so I'm
just drawing red ellipse here and the
principal axis of this ellipse respond
to the I interactions of H and the
statistical condition number of
acquittal is essentially the sum over
all of these eigen directions of e
transpose X I square divided by the
expected value of e transpose it's I
square it although other hand the
combination of condition number that we
have defined is norm of X I square they
are in 5 mins over the eigen directions
or expected value of 0 now you take the
summation or Ally
this is 35 norm of X I swear and then
you are replacing the sum in the
denominator with a minimum so it's so it
follows that dispensing of initial
number is always less than equal to the
computational condition number and
acceleration might be possible if this
really is much much smaller than haha
because today we are saying is kind of
information that we necessary for us and
if the information theoretic
power don't amount is much
you know thank you
then we can hope for activation to
happen think you're doing well put some
switches I see okay okay so what are the
values of these traditional condition
number and pockets of condition number
displayed and copulating set it's all so
far so in the discrete setting both of
them are not of the same order so we do
not expect any observation and the Ocean
City the central condition number comes
out to be about a hundred there as the
operational condition number comes out
to be of the order of 10 to the 4 okay
and let me try to illustrate like all
the things that I said in these two
pictures so the picture to the left is
the display distribution this one is on
the torsion distribution okay and the
y-axis is the error and x-axis is number
of vibrations or number of samples the
green plot responds to the performance
of stochastic gradient descent on TCP
and on the ocean and the pink dotted
line responds to the statistical the
initial number of 40 settings so here
it's about came to the fourth and here
it's about okay okay so now look at when
traffic radiates the second starts very
well on each of these problems so the
error starts to decrease rapidly after
this 10 to the 4 or 10 to the 5
iterations which is very close to the
condition of us and even here it happens
at a very similar takes about 10 to the
5 there so this really is the behavior
of the algorithm like I'm not giving you
an upper bound I'm talking about upper
bound but rather this is the true
behavior of algorithm and the pink
dotted line which is the lower bound so
there is very little gap between 0 and 1
and the components of custody here
whereas there is a big gap between the
lower bound and the performance of SGD
in this context so this again a
reinforce of stability a little tight
and then just keep setting at least we
know that absolutely is not possible
because there is no
between SVP and without one whereas in
the Ocean City it is a significant gap
between the lower bound and the
performance of the seating so there is
absolutely the same yes like your
definition of that and then it is a
solution to the horrible super victims
all eigen vector just a second yeah and
that you need to normalize very good
number the dimension also even in the
solid denominator so you know because
usually okay so you like in most your
samples are only one vector at a time
this is at least equal to the dimension
because if you don't even see dimension
number of factors your matrix is not
even for that typical covariance matrix
is not even further so this is usually
at least the dimension yes these are
eigen value scale and as you can see
here the mean this is the small segment
okay so what I have for you so far is
that the cases where observation is not
possibly those domestic setting there
are cases when it seems possible and the
next question is whether existing
capacity questions of like any ball and
desktop achieve improvement whenever
there is this gap in settings where
there is this gap between the lower
bound and upper bound topic release much
smaller than above and the surprising
answer to this turns out to be no and we
concern situations where security is a
key must honor than Papa but the rate of
capacity killing ball is no better than
that of capacity instead so by Omega I
mean that it actually behaves like this
because not it's not faster than so the
number of hydration is required for
heavy ball is at least in here in
condition number so this basically say
is that phonetically ball is no better
than is Jeannie and why we like why we
can like
for this anyone the same statement seems
to be true integrity for nets or
isolated aviators wealth and I also
point out that the distributions that we
construct here are actually taking a
natural PCB and in fact if you look at
the Gaussian example that saw earlier so
I'm going to helium also providing heavy
ball - rock it seemed to be like pretty
much on top of each other so and they
don't really do any better than to catch
a gradient descent oh the answer to this
question is that the existing algorithms
if you wanna an impossibility gradient
are really a key improvement in the
stochastic setting even where it might
be possible if you were just good CDs
over some point
what's that's right and what's happening
is you're just missing the truth
oh no I don't need you opportunity for
saying so here you're resampling from
this yeah I mean yeah really think that
like this is a motion so we have mean
fresh samples every time from the same
language yeah if you would say just yeah
so even then you will have this issue
because then your description is not the
coefficient but then at discrete points
X but even if you don't really also at
the friction with heavy pollen so even
in those setting here acceleration
no you don't get unless you are using
like fullback gradient descent so let me
come back to what the end of this talk
is explicitly
find out why wherever everyone s
propagate implement oh yeah yeah I also
think that exists cases or you can see
in this case generation the most or in
some sense yeah so I'm not okay so let
me put this in context so I'm not saying
that they never get solution that's not
the point that I'm trying to make I'm
saying that as a
don't get it maybe there are like very
special problems where they look at it
but I'm saying in terms of like universe
kids it does exist cases where you don't
gather and I'm saying there aren't like
some like pathological give us that I
cooked up but rather like sayin after
this like very just one what happening
so this brings us to the final question
which is whether we can actually design
an algorithm which probably improves
upon the performance of this TV in all
the situations where there is a big gap
between acquittal and Papa and we do we
design such an algorithm which we call
accelerated stochastic weenie descent or
HDD for shorts which improves the
condition of our dependence energy D
hahahahaha yeah so because I believe
always when you go to Papa this is
always improvement or worth of us right
and better work of art will tell you
much more than Papa this is a
significant improvement over okay so
this do mean to say what algorithm that
we have okay
so there's again like a little
demonstration of our algorithm is that
right so in this case the station number
is about a hundred so we expect a speed
up of about ten because we have this
quarter and that's basically what we
absorbing between both like greatly in
design and the right AC as well as I
click on install and
hdvs one more thing is that there is
still a large gap between the lower
bound pink line that we have here and
the performance of our algorithm and we
do believe that this is probably
unimprovable
because of computational reasons but
there have market be any lower bounds
combinational lower bounds on the
performance of specific algorithm so
will be an interesting that in 50 go
through like either improve the
algorithm or show that it's not possible
so what is the algorithm that we use so
the algorithm you it's hard to give a
very good infusion but let me buy a
high-level picture so the way that
people convert didymus acoustic
algorithms so the natural actually they
need in particular is that there is a
high-tech version which I told you about
in the beginning which has this
interface off we have a gradient with a
moment of steps and that's the one
that's widely used in practice there are
also other ways to write this activity
3d descent in little fist exciting and
one of them is this for a big question
because it affects of upper and lower
bounds - you have a primal and then you
have a dual and then you are trying to
minimize the difference between the
upper bound and the lower bound and you
can also think of themselves absolutely
free in descent trying to do this and
there is a different for a great
question is fixating both of these
algorithms are exactly the same
it has a gradient systematically games
right Tigers will become actually
completely different they're no longer
the same so the algorithm that we
propose is essentially this for a quick
version with using stochastic opinions
rather than radiance Q so that it is
amines Tama s versatility bring it or a
version of such a rigid finian but it is
important the way you experience it
specifically game design is static
gradients not all of that will give you
the same algorithm and doing it more
carefully turns out to be the right way
to ask you I'll maybe spend like few
minutes on the high level Ori of the
blue so as we saw it like there are two
comments though guarantee so there's
this first term which depends on the
tension of work and then logarithm and
then the second half it depends on the
my slaves right so this so in 500
analysis of the stochastic based method
it turns out there is what is known as
bias-variance decomposition and this
first term is known as the bias and the
second half is known as the variance and
this is a nice way to recover them so
you can analyze them
like separately and that's what we do so
for the first time the main magician is
that if you look at the potential
function that is used in the roof of the
difference across from that for
saturated radiant it has two entries
right WP & VT and then potential
function that one uses and measure the
error WP and we depend on so you measure
WT in the hedge now it is the poorest
Midlands and in the VD in the eggnog so
the mini magician that we had here was
that actually plays this hedge and do
not find any powers of H to the a and
into the a minus one and the same
analysis goes through and in the
stochastic setting it turns out that
using the a to knob here and then the H
inverse norm here is writing and that's
what gives you the right depends on
dependent substrates and once you do
this you get standard answers that
potential continent P usually equal to
one minus one hospital and put it up 30
minus one and this gives you this
geometric DK and despite of Kabakov
acquittal that is that you see here
basically what gives you a spawning term
okay yeah so you said yeah why do you
say this okay so so there are different
analysis also so this can have a
different analysis they don't like Grady
a moment of my conviction and score it
like a lower bond intubation he's
basically what gives you this kind of
potential function analysis so I don't
know if I have very good intuition so
somehow like this offer and lower born
into patient values over better to the
stochastic second for the radiated
momentum interpolation it's not clear
even the proof not even not clear at all
how go into it but when you look at our
end goal born into patient and you have
gradients with special ingredients here
that you happen to mount a variance in
suddenly and then it's yeah
so it's not like I don't have like so
much more intuition and what the book
tells me so this was about like the
first term in the convergence part and
then there is a second term which turns
out to be like month-old challenging and
the main reason for the challenge is
that any kind of potential function
argument where you keep track of single
scalar quantity I understand how it
decays every step does not seem to work
and seems to be extremely loose so you
have to essentially keep that off like
the entire covariance matrix so if WB
and Yugi are the high path then Peter D
is awaited solve these hydrates at the
air stem and here at each response I did
see doc a satisfying the Spice Girls
linear recurrence property and will you
expand Peter - I do
pretty much like after a large number of
steps you get this nice closed form
expression minus B inverse there B is an
operator that acts on ESP theories it's
so essentially new artists and designers
bieber's transpose
fortunately like we have a values less
than 1 so this actually is meaningful
but then we actually have similar values
greater than 1 which means that you
cannot have to use some food upper
bounds to operate a norm of B to
actually do the analysis and the baby
hold on this is to actually solve one
initial versions of this problem
so we have like for cross for kind of
problems then you solve this in this
each dimension and then you use an Asian
upper bound and definition of a bound to
put my various dimensions that we have
solved a single thing so while all of
this is pretty technical and like white
in what though I like there is one nice
kind of statement that you can say which
is that you look at W T and you say it's
for your face it's less than equal to
fiscal condition number thanks it was
first theta times I think oh this
becomes so this gives you a way of
bonding the obedience of the hydrates
okay so let me try to get whatever we
have seen so far so for Egyptian we have
pretty much completely correctly
understood given of various algorithms
really the same heavy ball Nesterov and
then you know absolutely page a design
and you showed that hitting ball and a
stop don't really provide and implement
the worst case so sorry there's a CD it
does provide a point or all of these
other other now the question is like we
have having adulthood these questions
for the linear vision problems then in
your do any of these conclusions have
any relevance to more complicated
problems in particular a trainee neural
networks there's many of these equations
actually help us in understanding these
things better right and the first
question when you come to this practice
question so the first question that pops
up mind is in fact is people having it
absorb that I think every ball and
install work much better and very
innocent in practice so aware as we are
saying that immediate vision like you
don't really even not really expect any
moment so what is the main reason and
you believe that the main reason for
this is mini batting so if you so if you
think about it so if you have a large
enough mini batch size you're pretty
much doing exactly the same because I
think there is depending on how it's
done and the settings in the data mini
pad size of 128 or 256 then that may be
already be enough to give you pretty
accurate estimate of the gradients right
and in the domestic setting we know that
eighty ball and instead of doing doing
doing digits so if you have a large
enough mini batch size you do expect to
get improvements from hitting balls and
a straw and what exactly is smaller
large
mini batch or those exciting to be close
to that it's fist exciting depends on it
varies from data aggregator say but on
datasets that use in practice one would
think that the minimize hides that we
are using is reasonably
who reduce the variance in the
stochastic radians and that's why he's
heavy ball and a stall methods actually
given four minutes and when you are a
leader the way GD would be like you can
improve on the competence of this unique
given for all mini batches because for
that information even if a small batch
size of one people still expect some
increments over all these rather yeah
yeah if you try to increase DVD which
says we have right I don't have those
pictures here but it's gradual like it
gimme ball and I stop gradually get more
and more human like us to me yeah so
these estimations we don't really have
yeah so okay so the wave upon topic will
change with the mini patch is that till
some points against between linearly and
after some point be saturated somewhere
so now let me show some empirical like
experiments that we did like if I get is
your performance off a CD as well as
understanding whether like this indictor
about media batching is reasonably fun
so the first experiment that we did was
painting in deep autoencoder for in this
using a very small mini batch size of
one and on this so here we see rod for
stochastic gradient descent any ball
iron as well and all of them are pretty
much top of each other and we don't
really see any improvement or excess be
capable and in four methods or HDV
when you use like this one we give a set
of one a and at the same time use the
isolated algorithm HDD we do see some
improvement in the performance of in the
speed of convergence of HDD up by two
so this is what was very small in the
bite size of one and we try it again
training error snide on the C part and
dataset again for a small mini pie
series of eight and so here the product
for SVP heavy pollen desktop and get ENC
right like there is not really much
difference between the performance of
these three methods and if you look at
Nesterov which is a representative
example here which like initially it is
like the smallest error so if you plot a
GD with respect to next off so easily
definitely the same asymptotic error but
it will HL ever faster and so even for
this small batch size yeah this is a
customer and we did hyperparameters but
just to get like the best test accuracy
I mean so I have a character such as are
usually kind of tricky to it like
totally so we did our best to move it
right and so if you look at as a HDD it
has like one more cat the parameters
ants nest or hitting ball but we made
sure like that the number of total hyper
parameter runs runs for each algorithm
is the same not like they are most
because they are more hypothermic I find
it even for like usual batch sizes that
use in practice like 128 or training per
second again on c510
we see that like a CD indirect keep the
scale accuracy but then it is ensure a
significantly faster rate so if you have
anything that exploratory search for
hyperparameters there we don't want to
have all the hyper parameter runs on all
the way to the end but rather run till
some point what is better wants to pick
out and so on in those cases this is
like our algorithm put help speed up the
hyper parameter terms and so that's all
I have to say so let me just wrap up in
the
like in the domestic setting this all
right maybe a design has been high
dependence on the condition of Earth and
actually a design improves upon the
defendant with a spiral the
approximation setting is video game has
the screen reference of condition number
and the first question we did not hear
is whether this can actually improve
anything better and it turns out that
you cannot always do it and there are
some cases where you can do it
I'm the parameter the cap is where we
can do it or not is this critical
condition of the property and we design
an algorithm which actually improves
this power to exploit of and you also
show that finality questions of like
popular momentum methods like heavy ball
and escrow not get moment well the
problems we have try to evaluate it even
one like more complicated models like
training zero like books and so on and
the intuitions that we gain from the
series into really any or even to just
more complicated settings and finally we
also have for our algorithm on high so
if you are training these models peace
until using core algorithm and let us
know if you have any comments or
questions during its query point is zero
yeah so C must when I come up with a
lackey I defend so in stochastic linear
equation right there are two pairs of
noise one is I'm sampling an X which
rather than like giving you the entire
distribution of X another one is if I
give you an X my observation y is equal
to X transpose W star plus some additive
noise there are two gate of -1 is idea
but another one is multiplicative and in
the sea
captivated minds and to stop a quitter
who captures the police is what is
called oh my goodness so because I have
this a convulsion distribution right I
don't see the entire distribution at
once I only see one sample so that in
war comes in this power even if I hit an
X so I get not exact so it's not just
one learning rate because the algorithm
has like a bunch of parameters so the
learning so there is one thing
so there are mini Mesa game to look at
it you can look at it as a whole
learning rate which corresponds to the
usual learning rate which is like 1 over
K so same logic video uses FC and then
there is a long there is a lot of a
larger lurking bit which is more like 1
over so the small step is one over this
one step times and then there is one
more I don't think so that's what I was
saying that so there is a big gap
between like the lower boundaries would
you intend the performance I believe
it's not possible to throw up on this
rate but it'll be an interesting tie
either way if you can design a better
algorithm because any better I'll give
them or show a lower bound
but I believe that a lower bound
questions all right let's think anything
[Applause]